hey what's up party people welcome to
honest trailer commentaries uh before we
started uh we were talking about the Man
in the Iron Mask and now I can't stop
thinking about it but today we're g to
talk about blue be um Blue Beetle is a
film that we watched a couple weeks ago
and made an honest trailer for us so
we'll talk you through it if youall are
behind the scenes Deep Thoughts um
questions and comments go in the chat
we'll answer those at the end as well as
some deleted scenes that I believe we
save for you um and then we'll tease you
with next week's oh boy honest TR we're
gonna make some we're gonna make some
powerful enemies I feel like we've
already pissed off that contingent
enough yeah you're probably you're
probably right probably right that they
they they found the door at this point
but they'll be back to yell at us next
week yeah there were definitely some
people in my feed like you're not a true
fan if you don't appreciate this it's
like sorry I'm sorry to that guy right
now all right Blue Beetle um a film that
I would describe with words like nice
good you're not a true fan not okay I
enjoyed uh if I have different grades
for it if I compare it to other
superhero origin stories I think it's a
good one of those unfortunately I have
to compare it to the 300,000 superhero
origin stories we've gotten in the last
20 years and it's just like it's it's
that again it's one of those um I think
they did a much better job with the
background characters um I I what do I
know but I didn't think like the Mexican
culture Stuff felt forced at for the
most part and out of place it seemed
pretty naturally woven in and I liked
all the liked all the performances but
it's a superhero origin story times a
thousand that you've seen a million
times before he gets he gets the powers
he he makes some mistakes he learns he
grows credits rooll tease for the next
one yeah I I feel like there there is a
world where this never became the
dominant genre like superheroes always
remained like kind of one of those like
mostly for younger people kind of under
the radar sub genres and this would be
like one they bring out one big
superhero movie every like three years
and this would be that one it's from
like an alternate universe where like
the 9s set the template for how
superhero movies were going to be
instead of the ODS and I feel like if we
lived in that world I would have liked
this I would be like yeah this is
exactly what a superhero movie origin
story kickoff to a new character should
be like it's quick it's funny there's
pretty good action uh you know I I like
the character I would want to go see
another I whether that will actually
ever happen who knows it's a crazy
Tangled Mor ass right now but I would be
willing to go see another highe re as
Adventure or see him finally get to meet
up with this version of Ted cord I think
it does a good job of launching that uh
it's it the problem is nothing to do
with this film it's exclusively like we
just went back to this well a 100
thousand times and we're all kind of
worn out on it yeah um it's weird that
DC has this kind of like two-pronged
strategy of like the Zack Snider of it
all and then the Shazam of it all like
the more
CW RP influence stuff this definitely
falls into the latter category and like
yeah it just like it's it's fine it's
it's good even it's just not sticky like
there's nothing I will remember about
this except for like George Lopez I just
I feel like we keep coming back to these
stories and not to knock the people who
came up like they're they're Geniuses
they're great writers I I love all those
old silver Age golden age comic book
writers but but they they were knocking
these things out quickly they were
purposefully making them very similar to
All the Other Stories because that was
the job it was like well we need to have
our character that's like our version of
this character they knew what was
working they knew what the formulas were
these were comic books for children
decades ago like we're we're pushing to
the very limit of what you can do with
these kinds of formulaic stories these
guys were knocking out eight issues of
this in an afternoon you know it was
like scrawl it down so we can run down
to the corner and get our sandwiches you
know and I feel like now we're coming
back we're treating them like these holy
texts like this like this Mana this
scripture that we have to like protect
the guard it's like man Blue Beetle that
was just like an afternoon they just
came up with something you know it was
it was so casual in its day and and now
we're demanding that it become our myth
you know yeah we want these to be like
The Iliad and the Odyssey there are core
Foundation stories and it's like blue
Beetle's kind of silly like it was it
always was and and you know and I I like
that about this movie that they're kind
of like a little bit aware of that and
like the Ted cord version is kind of a
goofy throwback uh I thought that was
fun okay well let's let's continue to um
tear down the monomyth the iconic class
that we are here at on trailers and
watch uh the Blue Beetle one let's uh
let's roll
it
[Music]
I can't hear it neither can I fast with
Batman cut Superman down to size and
sent Wonder Woman To The Cameo zone now
DC is shrugging a m for Max film into
theaters while their Universe Burns as
their newest hero shows up to a party
after the host shat on the couch and
sent everyone home Bano alesta
blue
beetles did you see the uh the story
today about I just saw that clip of
Mamoa uh passing out yeah he was
apparently drunk and dressing like
Johnny Depp on the set of Aquaman 2o is
what they're saying they're also that
story also had a paragraph where it's
like no one is returning as their DC
snye characters which like really
because I thought I thought I thought
James had been saying a few of them were
going to come back yeah including solo
it's like and I feel like with um where
we left off in the flash is really
anyone can be anyone you can have George
cloney as bman anybody could be anyone
yeah but no they're you're right they're
they're saying The Peacemaker that crew
is safe like those John Cena and and
Viola Davis and those people will be
back but otherwise this article seemed
to imply no like G GDOT is out and uh
Mamoa might come back as a different
character but not Aquaman and anyway
yeah who knows who knows this um just on
the previous point you know semi
unrelated uh I feel like any actor of
sufficient Fame and like um and and um
wealth ends up looking like Johnny Depp
like I think that you get you cross a
certain threshold and you just Rings
start appearing on fingers scares show
up the the V on your T-shirt gets deeper
and deeper the more movies you're in
yeah all of a sudden chains you just
start wearing chains you never you don't
know where you got them yeah you didn't
start wearing you know the blousest
pants known to man but suddenly they
they're uh yeah your Jorts just got
ankled deep anyways uh let's move on
let's keep playing a hero who is
definitely still canonical even though
this movie isn't as you welcome the most
beloved Latino hero of all time to your
screen George Lopez is that the new time
I got you he's Rudy the only conspiracy
Mery minded Uncle to somehow Dodge qon
so if you made him the Blue Beetle this
would be 10 times more interesting
Batman's a fascist but instead we'll
settle for Cobra Kai Zolo marida he's at
the magical time in a new star's life
between their first starring role and
their first set of veneers as he takes
on the part of haime Reyes a good kid
from the wrong side of GTA Vice City
does anybody in this town know how to
drive oh okay okay okay oh my God
Everything Will Change when he contracts
a mean case of superhero origin I just
want to just briefly um you know go down
the elseworlds path of if George Lopez
got to play Blue
Beetle Oh you mean in like in the 90s or
today let's do both I mean classic GE
take your pick yeah that would have been
incredible absolutely incredible there
was a very frustrating like five to
seven minutes of me working on this
trailer where I wanted to reference
George Lopez's previous superhero role
and I was sure he was in a Spy Kids
movie I was I could picture him as the
villain in a spy you know he's got that
like the monitor in his face is taking
up the whole monitor but I couldn't I
kept I looked up all the [__] his movies
he wasn't in the credits I was I was ter
out then I realized Shark Boy and Lava
Girl oh that's he's the villain in he's
not the villain in a Spy Kids movie he's
the villain in the Spy Kids adjacent
film Shark Boy and Lava girlfri reading
so there you go that that was that that
was my big George Lopez yeah I just
think it'd be funny if today's George
Lopez you gave him the Blue Beetle suit
forced him to get abs why not I mean you
don't need ABS the suit is doing
everything you know you're just in the
suit you you could be anybody in that
suit that's true I was gonna say like we
should give um you know Comics more
superhero roles but I feel like that
with Paul Rudd I guess he's not a comic
but um comedy first people Chris Pratt
and stuff like that they got super and
it worked but also you get you get blank
man sometimes you get blank man but
there are so many suit based Heroes you
really could you don't need to do and
not everybody needs to be a Hemsworth to
do the superheroing a lot of them get
their powers from like magic like Doctor
Strange could be a heavy set guy there's
no it's just magic it doesn't yeah but
they always have they always have a
shirtless scene in there and the the
actor always gets real excited to like
you know do their men's health article
and and work out for six months I'm just
saying you like there are plenty of
these Heroes that like Josh Gad could do
it there's nothing stopping Josh Gad
from doing it it's just a suit based to
anyway but there's a weird like comedian
to steroid pipeline you know Chappelle
carrp jogan Gallagher right is it g no
carot car carop swole um damn he could
be a villain by himself just ripping
people to pieces with this massive
Carrot Top um all right keep going
symptoms of which may include itching so
itchy this thing
burning oh my God I'm on fire and weird
boners hey guys I'm than the nothing
happened her mom
died I feel a search of blood rushing
towards your mid
region I cannot believe like look
they're both Attractive people but that
was wild that um they make out right
after she tells him about her mom dying
yeah they go they go they switch very
quickly and also with the speed of which
look again maybe a younger man but like
um he had he was his pants were raised
like for that to for that to happen she
needs to be telling him about her dead
mom and he needs to be already at least
half torqued because it's like dead mom
dead mom kiss boner it's he needs to be
already on the way up well she very
she's very attractive so she might be
talking about dead moms but you
know like the teacher in the peanuts
like yeah he's already moved on to the
next like oh we're we're getting to know
each other better this is going to lead
to something this is GNA work I now I
haven't even looked up these two actors
I have no idea how close they are at age
but it felt it felt like they were they
it felt like they were writing her as
older than him until the romance started
and then I was like I guess they're I
guess they're the same age after all
yeah did he just graduate from high
school or college College college okay
so he's like2 but I thought they were M
like I and it's not that it's nothing to
do with how that actress looks or
anything about that it's just the way
that they present her in the in the
she's like a board member of like rathon
or whatever and I'm like okay it was her
dad's company so she's an aist so
whatever I guess age8 nothing but a
number as far as that goes but like I
don't know it was just a weird like I
assume she was supposed to be like 30
and he was supposed to be 22 and then
immediately they're like oh hey how you
doing I was like oh I guess they're both
25 I I don't know yeah I'm looking at
not a complaint just a thing I noticed
she's 28 and he's
22 problematic oh May December I'm not
trying to say that it's
fun I hate it when people kiss on camera
uh there's a huge power differential
because she's the CEO of a company and
he's uh the Blue Beetle some kid from
the wrong side of the there's no tracks
but side of the the bay the island yeah
the key the key right Edge key they're
on the edge Keys all right keep going
it's not
Miami hijacked by the Blue Beetle an
alien suit that's just as deadly and
effective as a fighter jet controlled by
your Alexa engaging threat
Eng got do something testing
acceleration systems fast do Fast close
overreacting you kidnapped me all right
C activate rebooting rebooting are you
kidding me together they could search
for where the Blue Beetle came from why
it's on Earth and why it shows Hae as it
they could just not do that you don't
actually care about Blue Beetle do you
they don't what the hell is Blue Beetle
like super mad at Metropolis with a
flash in Central City but just uh not as
good H it's kind of a let down if you
need an actor to fall in love with a guy
pretending he's in terrible pain you
call Neymar's X Neymar
football joke for you yeah what do you
think Mar is Jenny she's a billionaire
neog Board of her daddy CGI Army Factory
but if she were running things they'd be
a charity honest it's not about taking
from the community but giving back to
the community watch her play hide the
Big Blue Beetle box from Susan I like so
so cord Industries Stark Industries no
no shareholders there's there's clearly
nobody like hey we like selling weapons
that's how we make
money no she's um yeah but I I I didn't
get the sense that they stopped making
weapons just that they also now have an
initiative that's like you know they're
gonna build a library or two I think she
comes out and straight up says we're not
gonna make any more weapons We're not
gonna make that weapon uh I don't know I
don't feel like like if Sarah locked
took over tomorrow like I don't feel
like they have the option to just stop
yeah we've actually put a lot of R&D
into these laser guided death missiles
so this kind of this radar is like what
we do really it's like it's whole the
whole company's really that's like what
we do so we what we're gonna make uh
we're gonna make cookies now like what's
she's yeah she's gonna flip a big lever
from a um death bombs to cookies yeah
and then the factory changes up it's
like one of those comic book tropes
where it's just like people are good at
science and it's like in a general way
like you throw them any science thing
and they're GNA they're going to get
there like ant-man's daughter obviously
could figure out the quantum realm she's
good at science it's interesting it's
like the remember the law of um
diminishing ninja returns yes yeah so
for those who don't aren aware well in
in film one ninja is dangerous but a lot
of ninja are Canon F so it's like one
scientist is brilliant or one nerd is
brilliant but if you have a lot of nerds
like those are just nerds they don't
know what they're talking about yeah you
can put them on anything so like she can
go into court Industries tomorrow and be
like we're going to work on Green Tech
now and they're like okay that missile
forget it hey I'm building a big fan now
exactly uh all right keep going
Brandon's Victoria a super villain who's
contractually obligated to do at least
one racism per scene Dr Sanchez hello
actually that's not my name I will have
a cigar they're made by real Cubans
anday and who got her degree from the
same grad school as Dr Evil don't get in
my way Jennifer Target the family it
could kill him oh bummer we can learn a
lot more if we take it off his corpse
she's so evil the only explanation that
makes sense is if a bunch of dalmat drop
kicked her mom off a cliff as a
kid love
it a how can we how can we show that
clip more
often yeah I mean what Susan sandon she
just like she just wants a check right
like I or of course
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but as far as
where this character comes from I I
didn't do the research on if she's a
does she have a big Comics background I
mean even if she does she seems like
vioria cord I actually don't I I haven't
I haven't read that much Blue Beetle but
I don't oh yeah I guess so I guess she's
from the comics oh no Victoria cord was
charact created specifically for the
film so they
okay so no she just I wish she had like
a a must stach Tut twirl because she
might as well at in every scene yeah
it's it's I mean it is what it is like I
I I guess you don't have time to really
establish like fully the whole cord
family and really get into it but it's a
little bit over the top like she's just
so ridiculously evil and it it's like
her goal is just evil you know like it's
just like she's one of those like um
like Corey stolen Ant-Man where it's
like they're just Business evil like
they just want they want to do business
but even you kind of feel like even if
you get made them an even more lucrative
offer to do something good they wouldn't
take it they're only interested in doing
evil business things we should totally
make you know like the D and D alignment
chart with like Business evil science
science evil and Magic evil oh that's
right yeah yeah all your villains are
are one of those
basically business science or magic all
right I'm gonna make that uh all right
keep going have you seen Spider-Man Iron
Man Venom andman or Shazam then you get
it it's one of those take your pick
you're becoming symbiotic what's
different is its celebration of all
things Mexican Aman from on the nose
references like tacos and the Virgin
Mary to more deep Cuts Like ches burrito
or having at least one emo relative that
pulls off the rare feat of making you
care more for the unpowered background
characters then for the hero villain
action or backstory look it's not a bad
film but we just watched 30 super hero
origins in the last 10 years you're
going have to drop more than bug farts
on us to break out take
that yeah pause I mean that's the the
direction I'd take it if there were a
sequel slash if they ever um did this
over again is like give everyone in the
family A a beetle I think they actually
they every scene they were in it felt
like um was improved by having all of
those characters in it and when they
were when they weren't there I was I was
thinking we go back to the family like
that was fun I actually it's one of the
rare instances where I preferred that to
the the hero and the villain yeah I I
mean I think they they did a this would
be a disaster if they hadn't figured out
ways to make it feel like some on some
level its own thing you know because
otherwise you just get the superhero
origin tropes over again and we've seen
them a million times but I think they
did do a good job of that of making the
family giving them some personality
giving them some life uh I it's hard for
me to tell uh how many of these
references are getable if you didn't
grow up in Southern California like we
oh yeah we we need help on one what was
we get chapline Colorado but like I
don't know if you get that if you're not
from like it's on TV in Southern
California yeah what was that one that
we were we were like wait is that a
thing or is that just oh this movie I
can look I can look through our slack
yeah um you're right we're going to help
with we're gonna need help tracking down
if this is a like I had to look up Maria
L delario I didn't know that one but I
need choline Colorado immediately that's
that's Souther California TV fix um the
grandmother gives the sister a lemon a
lemon wedge they're about to take off in
their bug ship so I feel like it's some
sort of plane like before the plane ride
she gives her a lemon wedge to suck on
and it's like two things why does the
grandmother have fresh lemon wedges with
her she's got a tupperware full of lemon
and slice lemon is that a thing like
before you take the go on the ride on
the plane or whatever you suck on a
lemon is it like the the the chewing gum
thing that Americans do or I was really
Abita just like is she losing it so
those your let us know a cultural thing
it's like your grandma having fresh
lemon slices on her is that a thing in
the in the Mexican world I've never
heard of that my My grandmother used to
carry a banana in her purse with her in
case she got hungry that's a different
thing she did she that's just a snack
she had an she would carry an emergency
banana she used to call it in her purse
in case she got stuck somewhere and she
was hungry it's a little my U all right
let's let's keep going forany fun
superhero adventure that's maybe the
1,000th movie to end up with two guys in
identical Su suits fighting but still
makes the the most out of a solid cast I
deserve a luxury dump right now all
right a great score and a promising
young director and who knows if enough
people watch it on streaming maybe it
will get a sequel after all tell her
that your dad is alive Ted cord is alive
see Ted cord's alive Ted cord he was the
original Blue Beetle well kind of he's
the one that found the scar but it was
actually a professor named Dan Garrett
who the suit chose is hey where you
going story hi May I be your Iron Man
Jen things you'd never expect to hear
five-time Oscar nominee Susan sandon say
out loud without the Scarab we can't
complete the omac carac ready the claw
the Scarab chose you but it belongs to
me show me the car packs Simba you have
forgotten me Miss lorville Greg guara
what we do in the lab coats and Uncle
trucker a bug
Strife so blue Beetle's one of those
Heroes who won't kill no killing he
should really tell that to the rest of
his family it's like a can
[Music]
miss lasers maybe got to do what you got
to do yeah they're fine they're fine
maybe they're non lethal might be
something and they decided to work there
so they're evil they took a security job
at course they took a security job at
like a big tech company like I don't
know if they necessarily knew Susan
sandon was
evil it's a it's a fair assumption to
make I don't know you're just like yeah
we got this lab on this island we just
need you to keep secure the perimeter
like you wouldn't necessarily be like I
bet they're doing evil science in there
always assume they're doing evil science
in there I mean anywhere that has a
anything with a universe yeah if if the
if if the CEO is not famous for going on
TV and announcing they don't make
weapons anymore they're they're
making um that's not what we make here
we make trailers honest ones um like And
subscribe no weapons hit the Bell uh
next week's gonna be really fun please
come back for that one and uh for this
week let's watch some deleted
scenes storying who's your favorite
Beetle mine's Paul XL man of war beat by
dway you're my boy blue do dude he's
ragging on your cord Jenny from the bug
AIS Bud Susan So Random Lazy Susan
sullenly Susan Metroid rage obadias Lane
Hefe Bridges cyberpunk
2023 Johnny moronic a wa lit your ass up
not
Sanchez and Rudy Rudy Rudy Rudy in
sector
Gadget Iron
Man uh Hey IMDb that's not his name it's
what
Francisco could be more clear about that
yeah come on IMDb you're not spoiling
anything by using his uh his character's
name well that's the the bit the whole
movie is that she susar resen racistly
calls him Dr Sanchez even though that is
not his name and then IMDb does the same
in s again it's
on all right uh let's go let's go on to
the Pito from Puss and Boots The Last
Wish okay how dare you that's true that
right or pay the price um let's move on
to the questions uh Benjamin obam coming
in hot why did DC fans claim to want
good stories and character development
but ignore films like Blue Beetle uh
Birds of Prey and which one's TSS The
Suicide Squad Suicide Squad yeah the the
James gun one while defending schlock
like the flash or black hat
uh I won't read this last part because
it's too inflammatory too hot wow too
hot for TV um uh are they he's
questioning their judgment well yeah
here's what I would say right off the
bat with any question like this is is
when you're when you're talking about a
group that's it's as as unclear as DC
fans I I feel like you're really talking
about a very vocal small group of people
on Twitter
SLX not DC fans RIT large so you got to
bear in mind that like you're only ever
talking about the the little
crosssection of fandom that you're
encountering on social media or whatever
it's not everybody like most people
aren't even aware of those arguments
that are happening on Twitter about all
these movies yeah that's fair um and I
would say you know um what whatever
they're claiming vocally or not like
people didn't show up to see the flash
or black adom any more so than they
didn't show up to see Blue Beetle or
Birds of Prey or The Suicide Squad like
none of those I think were were Bonafide
successes that that got Beyond like the
core superhero fan base right yeah I
mean right and and I mean I don't know I
think I think at this point it's it's
hard to say exactly how much it matters
that these projects are part of an
ongoing story that's still being told
like the franchise is healthy and
there's a future in it but we know that
it helps like it's obvious that not
being part of a franchise that's got a
long Healthy Future like knowing there's
this 2024 rip snyers date is obviously
impacting all of these movies and I feel
like we're not going to know until
Superman Legacy how much of an impact it
was having yeah but we'll probably see
it with Aquaman 2 as well the first one
made over a billion I doubt this
December Aquaman 2 is going to set the
world on fire like that maybe I kind of
doubt it not because people hate Jason
mimoa now or people hate Aquaman now
just because they know that this is the
last chapter in an old story not an
ongoing thing that they have to keep up
with the remain relevant yeah well with
that in mind uh May asked so is there an
upcoming comic book movie you're still
excited about I'm thinking only about
beyond the spiderverse yeah I'm excited
for that one that that's sure but like
TBD end of next year at the earliest
right um yeah I mean they're well they
gota they got to work on it and not make
everybody want to die who's animating it
for them so yeah they've got they've got
a little ways I mean
look there're still I I I I have hope
that there're they're gonna be more Good
comic book movies I don't think it's
like a dead genre I'm excited to see
mersel Ali's blade whenever they figure
that one out uh I'm I'm excited to see
whatever they figure out for fantastic 4
and getting the X-Men into the mix and
I'm looking forward to James gun's uh
you know
DC launch and what he's gonna do with it
yeah I I I'm still I'm still in I'm not
totally done with the entire genre yeah
I'd say I am most excited for Superman
Legacy because it's new yeah new even
though it's like the hundredth
whatever of everything but uh James
gun's a good filmmaker and it's a it's a
chance to start fresh and I think that
there's a reason why comic books do that
every yeah eight to 10 years so let's do
it with movies too and and I love the
idea of mimoa as Lobo I know people are
disappointed he's not gonna be Arthur
definitely Lobo is do we know he's Lobo
it's not it's not confirmed confirm but
it's been hinted around and suggested
and even that new article is like
mentions it again that mimo is probably
not coming back as Aquaman but maybe L
and that's why it's showing up
hammered everywhere because he's going
meth getting into character he's gonna
yeah soon it'll be a cigar a big
motorcycle starts spiking his hair out
yeah uh James bun asks what's your
Halloween go-to movie I hope you've both
seen ready or not I did I love that one
that was awesome I like Ready or Not
yeah um I was just talking on Twitter
not long ago a a childhood favorite that
I Revisited not too long ago uh and and
still holds up Ernest Scared
stupid remember that one I mean back
back in the day sure yeah I I loved it
as a kid and honestly still kind of
holds up but still still made me chuckle
on my most recent revisit uh another one
that I like a lot is uh trick-or treat
that Anthology one that Michael doy did
a few years ago okay you know trick
treat it's like it's like five or six
different stories all happening around
this one sort of suburban town on
Halloween night ran Cox is in it Anna
pin's in it good cast uh you know fun
like slight but but fun and and um qie
Halloween that Adam Sandler one on
Netflix too is better than you'd sort of
think it would be that's cool um I just
like to make a cup of hot coco um get
under a warm blanket and throw on um
audition um that's that's my Halloween
goto I mean horror a little bit of a
different flavor of it but you yeah
exactly um all right so but yeah keep
those uh send us some wrecks because I
could I could use some new horror movies
in my life um all right we'll end with
this um linger singor writes uh please
share five minutes of your thoughts
don't put me on the clock like that uh
on a go A Goofy Movie I love it so much
and I love the Honest Trailer can we get
a full honest trailer commentary for
that I don't know why we didn't must
have been like some time off or
something but um Goofy movie is so good
only gets better with age um it's
fantastic I don't have enough nice
things to say about it you you you're
born a Max you become a goofy with
wisdom I I wrote I don't know if it's
still up I wrote a video for fandom
years ago about it's still there yeah
yeah about Goofy movie is this kind of
transitional moment
where they suddenly Disney suddenly
discovered like oh in addition to these
like the great Disney classic animation
that kind of style we could do these
like fun self-referential kind of
snarky you know post modern sort of
animated movies as well and like that
kind of has taken over and become almost
the predominant version of Disney movies
now and I feel like Goofy movie was
really that moment where they discovered
like oh there's this other personality
that we could be pursuing aside from
like the story fairy tale you know
beloved animated Classics yeah like they
actually yeah I love goofy mov yeah they
they it it was set in the modern world I
mean the yeah pop culture jokes kind of
self effacing references you know like
they have Lester's posw and Park which
is kind of like a chance to poke fun at
themselves a little bit yeah yeah
um yeah like but revisiting Those Old
Worlds in a modern context so it's like
you're not totally removing like Goofy
and Peete and all of this like from
their original context but you're you're
updating them so they're more relatable
for modern audience yeah it's got comedy
it's got heart it's got Adventure um
it's perfect film uh yeah it's A Goofy
Movie and that's why we love it but you
mentioned power line the other thing is
like the songs are like it's it's a lot
better than you sort of expect it to be
yeah to go that hard so Bri Tevin
Campbell I thought oh you're right it's
Tevin Campbell wait is it hang on it is
I think you're right well we'll revisit
it just for fun um but I hope that hope
that satisfied your uh your goofy your
goofy lust you are correct it it's Tevin
Campbell that was that was M uh all good
um Bri Knight's got some jams too uh you
know what we're um we're going to we're
going to take off uh onto a maybe
another galaxy for next week um you'll
be surprised it's even uh more boring uh
than than the Galaxy we're in today um
but thank God they went to a new Galaxy
that was a different part of Northern
Ireland but what we're gonna bring back
with rocks in a different galaxy we're
bringing something back with us that's
really really G to um underwhelm um
that's your glue for next week God this
is a slog but we got through it and now
we get to really talk about it um yeah
likewise not a fan uh so come at us bro
next week right here on a triler
commentaries thanks for watching
[Music]
bye-bye